so anyhow less than 10 seconds cube
fanatics
I am entered 129 players 1755 roughly
average rating 30 minutes of crazytown
this double the points move get this
clock over here why did it go with d4
let's do this no matter what and then
just get a center push that night around
push that night around right now
Bishop takes pawn Knight takes Knight I
have a nice Center the bishops gonna
come back fishing
I'm gonna go fish I might want to go
fish my opponent is not gonna castle
they are gonna castle uh-oh somebody was
just asking me earlier when was the last
time you got a fishing pole thing going
on back to tournament fishing
everybody loves to go fish okay let's go
more fishing why not build a center kick
a bishop around space woo the Queen's
gonna get hit rook rook to see a
incoming the Queen's gonna be having a
headache very soon is she not Forks
around the corner b5 whoa I would did
not see that
did they see this probably they probably
saw that do this Knight takes Knight I
have to take this night with check first
in-betweener the king is running scared
the bishop has to move I'm still in a
pin you can grab that just take that
with check there's my knight gonna do
something dangerous it's the Queen dead
that Queenie dead let's hit her again
it's just wow this is dangerous this is
dangerous
Oh can my knight be dangerous here be
dangerous night this is so scary
get out of there bishop clean here this
is a good spot I think I'm watching over
stuff there might be a rook check tricky
stuff double checks and stuff I'm
hitting the bishop there's got to be
good stuff double-check
everybody loves double check everybody
loves a fork yes I have a fork Forks
should I just be pre moving this why not
no they resigned back to term in 12
somebody has 12 and I have 6 that one
got way too out of hand I didn't like
that more control over these games give
me more control double those points
let's go let's roll here Oh a clock
ticker oh wait Schwindt the points
double automatically I thought that that
was like a fix in these tournaments
where if you double the points okay but
yes that's what I was talking about you
got a move
you can't quick resign anymore are you
not quick resigned you can't just let
your clock burn anymore no you can't do
that you got to play you got a play
house that you got a play you got a play
to win the lottery lottery tactic I
insist I insist I still want to get
there I still want to get there I think
I can I think I can yes it can happen is
the night in a movie who loves it he
wants to move you know you want to move
power suggestion before kirovsky
light-square weaknesses where are they
where are those weaknesses huh you know
you want to take the pun you know you
want to take him I just Queen here I
don't have anything good Oh what is that
can I hit the Queen again she's running
out of squares she's trapped isn't she
she's running I was scared she
she's got it bright eyes what did I just
say running out of scares just play
chess quit it oh man let's go here hit
the night land a fork play g4 jump to f3
now let's go here right now and I cannot
be taken bad stuff around the corner I
could have taken with the fork Oh danger
stuff happening let me get this night
it's probably better move than that it's
gonna go here I go here
how's that for commentary if he's gonna
go here I'm gonna go there that was
really great that was really great back
the tournament twenty twenty twenty
seventeen twenty five minutes of change
double points move your pawns if you
want to move to e4 no your knight could
go to c3 tsunami of puns variation
they're gonna push no they're not they
probably should have played a five while
they had the chance
Oh Oh take that guy and now build my
little center and be happy about it
haha build that Center and be happy be
happy about it be happy about fishing
poles
get out of there Queen ah man okay I
give up I give up on the fishing pole
I'm just gonna Castle focus on f7 let's
come over here to g3 g7 is not too happy
Appanna g7 is not too happening okay f7
under fire push here if castles things
are happening whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I
have this though I have this the
trickiness everywhere I am on the Queen
I am definitely on that Queen oh there's
got to be dangerous stuff happening here
there's got to be very very dangerous
stuff happening this is a maintenance
and then to a 1 and then a 2 er back to
tournament 30 30 27 20 light of time
remaining there's a lot of players in
this one too
let's stick with what's been working c5
is sort of working c5 is sort of working
why not why not go with that why not I'm
still I insist even though it's probably
still bad then I could go here and stuff
sneak over oh I should have just taken
with the night Oh why'd I do that
that was stupid that was stupid
take my night and then fall for stuff
please I got something I got something
out of it I'm gonna take that one to the
bank I could promote that Kanna I'm on
each to be very scared each to everybody
fears that they got new g3 maybe uh let
me grab this pawn what's wrong with
grabbing him oh he's throwing a check
and then right here coming to life
Bishop c5 just don't drop your queen
whatever you do hit a knight chase a
night away grab a rook for free he's a
freebie that's a mate back to tournament
30 no 42:39 30 21 22 minutes remaining I
dropped back I'm not in first now is
this the guy that didn't play last time
he's at negative 25 this might be an
easy oh this is not a quick resigner
this is just a non mover a non mover is
what you call this one 15 seconds and
then that's gonna be it Clark Jake the
stakes have been doubled boom 5653 seven
games in I feel like I've played multi I
did I already play this guy I can't keep
track of all this stuff cannot keep
track of all this stuff another non
mover no more quick resign errs is just
non movers not over time the stakes have
been doubled boom what a fantastic game
that one
Wow this guy again Wow what is happening
here
this is ridiculous this is another one
double the stakes
efore he's at negative 29
I'm just taco I'm gonna I'm gonna toggle
my way to victory lane here who is this
is this like a coordinated effort
Clark Jake boom another Wow
it's like it's like like I keep hitting
the lottery here this is back-to-back
Powerball winners right here Wow all
right I'll take that little boost I'll
take that little boost I'll use all the
boosts give me the boost here come on
move your queen quit being silly move
your queen all right all right
a six you've seen it before I can't get
I can't get enough of it what can I say
okay I might still want to do something
dangerous what am I talking about okay
they're going King they're going to
Queen side they're gonna take that night
dark squares gonna give me the darks for
a bishop didn't give me it they
shouldn't oh I didn't want to do that
the night would have been stop it okay
I'll throw myself into a pen
he can't be taking advantage of Katie he
might be able to uh-oh
pawns are gonna push me around I have
this covered I could jump in here
barely I've stuffed barely working here
so now what what do you do you pile up
on here and say Queen go somewhere else
okay I'll do this and then stop that pod
from pushing okay
this night is out of play let's do that
I'm not sure why
that's a lovely reasoning right there
lovely reasoning everybody wants to do
that let's do this maybe I could get
this pawned later on dr. Seuss mode is
that what that is pawn push pawn push
again dark square weaknesses darks where
weaknesses get right here it's juic
square B to the knight could jump here
let's just drag queens let's go here
it's gonna be tricky tricky stuff
against e there's no time there's no
time let's just come over here let's
come over here take here I go here no I
can't go there let's just do that oh it
doesn't matter
there's no time two seconds is not
enough not enough not enough back to
tournament that got ugly 110 69 wow the
brown rook I gotta watch out for the
brown rook here okay
caro-kann I said it'd be okay I have a
space advantage I was gonna say I should
be going with the fantasy fantasy land
castle land war castles Greek gift errs
Greek gift where you at it feels so
right to just do this it just feels so
right
I shouldn't have no it's okay let's grab
here for a second I thought the okay now
I could do this is the King really gonna
go here that's crazy town isn't it crazy
town I want to keep this pawn right here
I want to target this pawn that's why I
did that
let's back up here I need to get out of
this pin I don't want to Castle
queenside as well it's gonna be safe or
isn't it no it's not I could go here um
okay let's pry open this right here are
they gonna give up the dark square
Bishop oh this is opening up very fast
that can't be right can it bishop could
give a check I could block but then I'm
in a fork the queen is dead 16 seconds
where's my clock
oh they resigned back to tournament 1:30
one-thirty spaz 1988 the stakes have
been doubled spaz knows all about
fishing poles I don't know if I should
even try it oh okay we have transposed
into an exchange variation of the Slav I
didn't want that oh this is too dry okay
all right let's let's get my rook on
scene I want to trade LightScribe
bishops they can try to make me know oh
man everybody's trying to kill me now
you fall for once scholars me everybody
tries to go for the sneaky stuff Wow
okay he was a bad guy anyhow I'm on the
Queenie problems Oh
just take the knight I still have stuff
though it's gonna be okay I think is it
gonna be okay I'll get out of the sneaky
stuff right here is okay I just want to
get rid of the LightSquared Bishop I
think can I do that No
let's get rid of the dark service up
right here just came takes doesn't
really matter I'll go here instead does
it matter King up if Bishop here or not
here Knight here a counter-attack
counter-attack night right here hits
everything doesn't it the bishop gonna
move let's just go here trade
give me that light square bishop my dad
might get kicked away I run here so I'm
losing a pawn but there's maybe some
stuff I should just got here no they
don't have any time let's break this
trades I said I was gonna have King up
why didn't I do that oh I just dropped
my knight haha it's gonna be here okay
whole comeback could take this and then
get rid of that thorn before it's too
late before it's too late should have
just taken the rook first might be a
pawn push it's bleeding the pin there
still might be a pawn push there is a
pawn push do I have this covered I think
I do I want to push again I have the
Queen there's no time time burners back
to tournament 150 107
fifteen minutes and change brown rook
again what's with these same opponents
the same opponents oh I didn't want to
do that that's a very ugly move to do
Knight takes pawn might be good
yeah there might be something to that oh
they're not gonna do it they ran home
they ran home they ran home what does
that even mean why'd you emphasize it
like that I don't have any answers to
that question if you're asking that I
have no idea why I would say something
like that Adam Sandler is what I was
thinking about happy gilmore to be more
exact was he too good for his home he
was not he was not too good for his home
he went right g8 okay bishop just take
the pawn no just castle I want to play
here order no probably here maybe get my
HP uninvolved sneaky stuff I'm on there
Queen they might miss it they did miss
it
I'm on the bishop and the knight if the
bishop takes here to help me are they
gonna do I got that guy and this guy
pieces are falling kitchen sink less
than 20 kitchen sink more pieces falling
pigs matin one threat got it back to
tournament 171 2700 13 minutes and
change um okay I having some grand prix
land let's get this in or your pawn push
I have a nice home I'm threatening this
pawn right now I'm gonna go back I want
to get to these squares I might want to
do this first though yeah let's get this
in to secure my Knights position for
when he is on f5 if Bishop here just go
there mmm hang on defend that pawn it
was hit twice after that knight move I
got this pawn who is there gonna be
something here I don't think so
let's just do this I think I might have
been able to take here I'm on it now I
think Bishop takes his force now there's
possibilities to take here I want to get
rid of this Knight he's a giant pain
Jayant pain I might want to stop the
knight here let's do this just move my
knight and have my bishop watch over b5
okay let's get my night doing something
c4 c4 is where I want to be and then hit
that b2 as well it's very uncomfortable
to the queen side now sometimes you
might want to keep this square available
to meet Knight c4 with Bishop back and
then it's boxing out the night okay just
push here there's it's very
uncomfortable let's push I can take this
Knight twice yeah I'm gonna do it now I
like my knight on c4 pile up on this
square next I have III covered
maintenance Rhett very uncomfortable
Bishop back I get this rook they might
do that they did and I keep the trade
Queens very soon let's just do this and
then throw in a check get those Queens
off the board I'm up I'm on g2 still
alright let's just know I could just do
this okay now that pond is officially
dead it's officially dead hit three
times defended twice can't be defended
again there's no time back to tournament
19147 ninety nine eleven minutes and
change Andrew alright here we go
Grand Prix Grand Prix sneak my queen
over here oh I guess I'm gonna have to
do that now huh okay I should just take
it a night okay I'll do it now Oh a
mouse slipper oh I know I know I know I
know what just happened I know you can't
take the bishop forks you're still gonna
do it though straight stuff just trade
stuff okay Oh
get over here Oh everything's fallen
kitchen-sink trade that's him I was a
mouse lip making one
let's jump over here whoa Kings going
crazy watch out for stalemate man one
threat that's game back to tournament
210 210 167 ten minutes and change he's
gotta beat me to the punch there Oh a
quick resigner to 32 31 67 107 run
Forrest
let's go Gump we've got a play against
run Forrest here run Forrest I know all
about that movie all about it all about
forest I'm trying to come up with some
quick quote here I should probably not
even say it I don't even know what I was
gonna say good movie movie I like that
movie
jumpin knight into this square right
chasin omega1 threat if the bishop moves
its main it's mate no matter what back
determine 250 Forrest Forrest went down
alright what happened in that game why
did I think I'm my opponent was going
with like a hippopotamus type of setup
I'm gonna take that and say no I didn't
mean say laughs I meant say show me show
me the compensation I was basically
saying by accepting that gambit get out
of there
stop d5 stuff defendant night I have a
nice pond wall gonna be broken down
we're gonna see about that
let's drain oh let's just trade let's
just trade why not the night does not
have a good home he has no good home and
well pieces are falling now let's come
over here defend stuff in here
target f2 that's where I want to be they
resigned back to tournament to 78
minutes and change
I have a lot of games in for more from
second place and I believe it's because
of the for either non movers or quick
resign errs take your pick
it's a lot of that going on a lot of it
let's go here I'm on g7 I'll take that
dark square bishop if my knight gets
pushed around I don't want to go here
King here I can't make use of that
Square than that the bishop went home he
went home I should just take in that
there's a queen gonna take it she is I
want to do this just to get this pawn
advance in uh I still want to get this
in can I get it in I got it in take with
the bishop let's do this get back to
this square hit the Queen they can't
castle in either direction now clean up
if Queen e6 trouble I'll get rid of the
dark square Bishop okay let's do this so
I could get to what square next g5 let's
take this we're gonna have a bunch of
exchange now let me hit the clean first
probably scared when they see that oh oh
now there's pig incoming a pig pig pig
pig pig pig pig let's go here heading
that pond hitting this pond it's
difficult to defend oh I almost just dub
wondered I think she's blundered there
pac-man mode
pac-man mode get h4 in my king wants to
be on h6 can I make that happen I want
to inconvenience this it's Bishop can I
sneak my king up let's go here that's
gotta be uncomfortable sneak my king up
g5 is where you want to be isn't it AB
this pond I could go here right now
right here and now push my pond to
Victory Lane keep pushing keep pushing
keep pushing don't stop don't stop what
you're doing what you're doing is good
keep pushing
I should probably should have done that
sooner instead of doing like some fancy
king walk how about my king is here now
to deliver main knick knacks no matter
what got it back to chairman 290
um trouble there's trouble there is
trouble going on in this tournament I
don't like these kind you're gonna have
to just believe me I really don't I
don't like these okay yeah there's a
pretty good lead going on here
there's nobody closed now because of
those resign errs Knight g4 all rights
just stop Knight there if they can't
I'll do that and then my king could
reside on e7 I was gonna take with my
queen okay let's go here yeah I could do
that let's go here c5 is where my knight
wants to be oh there's got to be
something here soon right take with my
clean work against this punch just push
here I want to keep things closed okay
now there's some possibilities of
getting out my king let's come back over
here target that pond there might be
something quick take my bishop on that
again the Queen can't go there overtime
or uh or even with the time oh I have
sneaky stuff happening take and then um
I could do this boom boom boom boom boom
I think it would be made or something
I'm too scared oh no I just dropped this
pawn
oh they didn't take it I was calculating
rook takes pawn here and I backed out Oh
skip scaredy-cat mode it was scaredy-cat
mode engaged right there
scaredy-cat mode oh this pawns past my
Kings there to defend them I need time
burners as usual time burners time
burners time burners
have my roofs are stupid look at how
stupid they are yeah they're just
hanging out there I know I know all
about it let's just grab this pawn at
least take one of them down take one of
them okay my rook needs to go into
pac-man mode
there's no time though doesn't matter no
time back to tournament I yeah I backed
out I thought if I'm that age pon took
on g3 I think rook takes age to was
correct Oh a quick resigner 320 man this
isn't even close now ah okay 96 that's
like I have six wins because of that non
movers are quick that was like the third
click resigner I should just take in
here what are you doing go home what are
you doing just go home would you cuz you
want to be on f5 that's why you should
go home cuz it's gonna be a nice spot is
this this I think I played this guy
earlier yeah he's doing similar moves
okay and let's go here and then there it
can maybe take that pond and hang on to
it but now I can't there's gonna be a
bunch of exchanges and there's gonna be
a deadly deadly deadly skewer skewer
land skewers let's go here to take that
bishop soon the rook is gonna play to
see I'm gonna play to see and now to
avoid the nonsense right here avoid the
nonsense get out of trouble alright my
Queens gonna run home maybe now she'll
grab a pond I want to just guard this
square oh my Knights getting kicked
around sneaky night though but then
checking distance Bishop c6 is probably
good my opponent doesn't have a light
square bishop let's get on that diagonal
pawn push Knight move Queen pair up mate
get out of there rook oh there's gonna
be pawn push I might want to sack my
clean
can I do that let's try it let's try it
no no they're not taking my clean they
don't have any time though oh I'm on the
rook and this pawn depending on how they
react okay I have this now tricky stuff
happening right here no matter what
where's the mate they're down on time
back to chairman three forty two forty
five to forty three to twenty seven less
than two minutes ace ace the Kara pan oh
we're having this okay what do we do in
response to this we get our pieces out
nice and easy easy does it inside castle
um let's back up that night is
incredibly annoying and stop them from
getting to f4 let's gain some space and
get out of this same file and play to e2
probably want to do this as well or
actually this maybe I could pick up that
pond not quite now I could but it's not
without some drawbacks this night is
gonna come in here or there haha I'm
gonna get rid of that Knight let's trade
a bunch trade a bunch and then I want to
get rid of that night get out of there
night this is a little bit awkward I
really didn't want to have to do this I
want to attack that night next get him
out of there
this has to be uncomfortable I'm also
boxing out the knight by doing that so
my bishop is a little bit stupid but
also could I guess it could be pretty
good now that's annoying although I do
get the night there's there's probably
by petrol though I'm have to do some
dancing haha let's do some dancing
dancing time hang on I'm gonna dance out
of this anyway
come on you could do it oh this is gonna
be steal me oh the game didn't finish oh
man that that was a perpetual if you're
wondering by the way that final position
the game didn't end but it was gonna be
perpetual yeah I couldn't I couldn't the
Queen goes back and forth here and as
soon as I make use of a three she jumps
into a five that would have been a drop
it we had some more and all right